[Music]
these ideas so far
are nothing to tout and i don't mean to
single anybody out but we must pick a
weapon to deal with this crisis and it
can't be an
elevator full of ray rice there's one
bomb we have it causes mass blindness
the downside of which is it could blind
the pilot need someone to drop it and
turn quickly as well you could look the
other way that quickly
roger goodell look this isn't a game
they're brutal and brash their business
is booming they're stockpiling cash it's
got to be potent it's got to be big and
no it can't be adrian peterson and a
twig well if crippling growth and
freedom's the plan
this weapon here is the worst known
demand obamacare
i have apprehension seems cruel let me
check the geneva convention
the debt would crush him sir i assure
you i know man it is a weapons grade
entitlement program another plan and i
tell you i'm into this we come in from
the north and we hit them with stimulus
no
something traditional a bomber a pilot
uh we get it neil nfl players are
violent
like an emp to destroy all their c
drives we could send irs's top id
look the terrorists there are killing
their kin we should ban guns there
they'll turn their guns in they're not
paying taxes their growth is unstrained
guys consider doing a hashtag campaign
they're hitting oil they're making a
killing we'd stop their growth if we
could curb their drilling which weapon
to do so they all sound enticing i say
we ah heck let's just do the ray rice
thing
you